i have to keep it together i have kids
who can't see me fall apart he has to
come home he has no choice
i just let my fear be my strength
because i know one day i'm gonna be with
my wife and my baby
it is because of you that we are gonna
make it through you are more than just a
doctor you do it from the heart
every time you see the covetation you
can't help but say damn this can easily
be my mom
each one is getting harder and harder
it's tough to see people
constantly have to suffer
when we started chanting
i literally felt like my breath was
stripped away
i also heard all the times my patients
said i can't breathe
i have a pulse i have a pulse right here
pulse pulse pulse
what we've been doing here over the last
number of weeks is extraordinary and
special
and you are fearful you are stressed but
you raise the bar each and every day
that you get up and come to work
we weren't made for this
but i think this made us
i'm tired of seeing people like you in
the hospital your family cares about you
you got people who care about you
[Music]
you